hey guys good morning Rebecca ikamelo
was only 33 caught up in Thursday's
Crush at Brixton Academy she died on
Saturday morning as a result of the
injuries she sustained bubbly bright and
a devoted mum of two well known on Tick
Tock for her videos on parenting an
autistic child I post a lot of videos on
there for like any moms who are like new
on this journey even when I speak to
people now like they message me and
they're like oh my gosh like you're
doing such a good thing talking about it
like I wish I could do it as well and
I'm like you can you can do it as well
but they're just like I'm just not at
that stage yet so I don't know maybe
it's a process
Rebecca icamello had been among the
crowds here in freezing weather and
slippery conditions she and around a
thousand others had turned up to the
final sold-out show of afrobeats singer
Asha K who was told to stop performing
when conditions outside of the gig
became unsafe
in a statement on social media the
singer said I am devastated by the news
that Rebecca ikamelo who was in a
critical condition since Thursday has
sadly passed away let us please keep her
family in our prayers I've spoken to
them and will continue to do so I am
overwhelmed with grief and could never
have imagined anything like this
happening two other women caught up in
the crush a 21 year old and a 23 year
old remain in a critical condition in
hospital while an urgent police
investigation is underway to work out
exactly how things went so wrong that
this young mum lost her life Katie
Spencer's Sky News